de nuevo un sol abrazador consume todo a
su paso y con él regresan incendios
forestales al oeste de eeuu junio fue el
mes más caluroso en 127 años según la
administración oceánica y atmosférica
estadounidense y el servicio nacional
del clima calificó las condiciones
climáticas de este fin de semana como
peligrosas con temperaturas que podrían
alcanzar los 54 grados celsius en el
valle de la muerte en california una
reciente ola de calor que devastó
principalmente canadá también dejó
decenas de muertos en la unión americana
así como pérdidas multimillonarias la
ola de calor trae consigo inconvenientes
para los residentes de la zona o
sistemas viejos suelen dañarse en días
calientes no aguantan el calor se
sobrecalientan y las cosas se dañan
oregón idaho nevada y utah y arizona
están entre los estados que se
encuentran bajo alerta como lo evidencia
el mapa publicado por el servicio
nacional del clima a pesar que el
termómetro roza los 49 grados en el
joshua tree' national park en california
los turistas buscan disfrutar el verano
aunque extremando precauciones will
smith trajimos una nevera llena de agua
asegurando que todos se mantengan
hidratados estuvimos una hora o dos solo
asegurándonos de estar seguros
stay fire un reciente estudio liderado
por 27 científicos de la organización de
world water activision concluyó que la
reciente ola de calor habría sido
virtualmente imposible sin el cambio
climático generado por el hombre